l'hôpital et la maternité de mario paul
à feu et à flamme après les
bombardements russes
ce cratère montre l'impact d'une bombe
tombé non loin du bâtiment les
survivants qui peuvent encore marcher
fui l'enfer une femme enceinte est
évacué sur une civière une autre femme
le visage ensanglanté quitte la
maternité en vie mais sous le choc que
ce député ukrainien confirme la tacc
russe mais aucune confirmation de la
part de la russie
des locaux de la maternité il ne reste
plus rien des murs arracher des
incubateurs projeté par le souffle des
missiles le port stratégique de mario
paul est assiégée depuis neuf jours par
les opposants continuent ce chiffre on
découvre une bombe et
[Musique]
un blocus qui a fait plus de mille morts
selon les autorités de la ville on a vu
aussi des images de tombes de masse
affecte ayant autant il ya des morts
c'est à dire qu'ils sont et se précipite
pour intérêt les gens dans cette ville
assiégée où tout manque
l'électricité l'eau la nourriture y est
encore en a au prix appris la mort d'une
fillette de 6 ans de déshydratation les
styles elles ont le droit de quitter
l'élu l'hostilité elle est si elles ont
le droit de recevoir de l'aide
humanitaire donc assiégée
coupée du de leur approvisionnement
attaquer les sixièmes tout ça c'est
évidemment il ya la convention de genève
mais on est visiblement face une armée
et un président qui a une détermination
qui outre pas systématiquement les
conventions de genève le droit
international et ont emprunté
la taxe sur l'hôpital pédiatrique de
mario paul le président hélène ce qu'il
a qualifié de crimes de guerre hier
encore il affirmé qu'il restait ouvert
au dialogue avec les russes mais qui
n'est pas prêt de capituler car cette
décision revient au peuple ukrainien qui
l'a élu il s'était même dit on vers un
con romy sur le statut des territoires
séparatistes du donbass
en attendant la mince lueur d'espoir de
prochain pour parler des ukrainiens
continue de subir les bombes et de se
terrer dans les abris je pense que plus
l armée l ukrainienne résiste plus la
société ukrainienne résiste plus ils
sont en colère je veux dire les russes
plus rare colère une colère qui
repartira de plus belle à l'aube d'une
15e journée d'invasion ici s1000 khayat
radio canada montréal